قلنا طبعا اسابيع راجعين الان نشوف ارقام
كرونه في الصين زايده مقاطع كثيره متداوله
من هناك بخصوص القيود والاجراءات الخاصه
وانه الصين بتتبع سياسه صفر كوفد يعني اول
ما بيتمرسط اي حاجه بيصير فورا اغلاق
وفحوصات للكل وتجديد للاجراءات الساعات
الماضيه بتسجل او تم تسجيل في الصين اكثر
من 20,000 اصابه جديده بكورونا ومن
الاجراءات اللي تم اتخاذها مثلا اغلاق
جميع اللي على اللي فيها طبعا لانه رصد او
تم رصد اصابه واحده داخل الجامعه يعني
دكاتره والطلاب جوه ما في احد لا يدخل ولا
يخرج جوانزو وجنوب الصين من المناطق اللي
فيها تفشي بزياده والسلطات اعلانات اغلاق
كامل في المدينه فحطت الحواجز ونزلت
السلطات واغلقت المحل والاماكن العامه لكن
السكان يبدو انه فاضي فيهم الكيلو خلاص مش
قادرين يتحملوا اكثر من هيك ونزلوا
للشوارع وكسروا باشو ورفضوا الاغلاق
[تصفيق]
عشان